so there's this thing in your head
called a brain and it seems to be where
thoughts and feelings and memories and
perceptions and everything else has
happened so it would be great to know
how it works the obvious way to see how
something works is to pull it out open
it up and have a look but when you do
that with a brain it stops working and
tends to upset its owner so what we
really need are ways to study brains
while they are working inside people's
heads which isn't easy but can be done
with a range of different brain imaging
techniques one of the popular techniques
is M eg magneto encephalography which is
much less scary than it sounds
magneto means magnetism and cephalo
means brain and ography means images so
magneto encephalography means images of
the magnetism of the brain because the
brain is made up of billions of cells
called neurons when the brain does stuff
these neurons are sending electrical
signals to each other which like all
electrical signals generate magnetic
fields magneto encephalography measures
and locates these magnetic fields which
indicate the electrical activity of
neurons which is the activity of the
brain with magneto encephalopathy we can
see the brain working as it is working
inside someone's head
the magnetic fields caused by brain
activity are tiny and faint so we
measure them with highly sensitive
magnetism detectives called squids just
like it use a highly sensitive
microphone to measure a very quiet sound
if you are measuring a very quiet sound
you'd have to do it in a very quiet room
or else you couldn't hear the sound over
the noise of air-conditioning next door
and cars down the road and you get the
same problem detecting the brains
magnetism of the magnetism coming from
nearby phones and computers and from the
earth itself to block out this noise
imaging is performed in a shielded room
built with thick layers of metal that
block magnetic fields from outside
another complication is that Squared's
are super-sensitive magnetism detectors
only work when they're cooled down to
about minus 270 degrees Celsius which is
almost the absolute coldest that it is
possible for anything to be liquid
helium can be used to keep the squids
this cold the squids are then arranged
in a sort of a helmet with a few hundred
of the detectors held right up close to
the head some specialized systems have
smaller helmets to bear
fit children the squids do need to be
closed because they only detect brain
activity a few centimeters into the
brain and even then only some kinds of
brain activity but overall Maj is still
a pretty great brain imaging technique
partly because the process is so easy
the subject just sticks their head in
the helmet lies very still and a
detailed record is made of their brain
activity it's non-invasive
meaning we don't have to cut anyone open
or inject anything or expose anyone to
radiation which a lot of the other
techniques do involve it also has really
good spatial and temporal resolution
meaning it captures a lot of detail and
can do so thousands of times per second
so we can see changes in brain activity
moment by moment techniques like Aug
have less detail and MRI can only take
an image every second or two it's
important to keep in mind though that M
eg doesn't show the physical structure
of the brain just its activity so Maj
scans are often combined with MRI scans
so we can see both together but yeah Maj
has a lot of advantages as a brain
imaging technique and because of these
advantages it's widely used in research
and diagnosis where it can show which
bits of the brain are active when people
do different things and which parts of
the brain aren't working in patients
some of the really cool things you can
do with M eg include brain computer
interfaces where a computer can monitor
and respond to brain activity in one
study a computer was set up to move the
cursor on a screen when a particular
kind of brain activity was detected by M
eg stroke victims who couldn't move
their hands learned to produce that kind
of brain activity they were able to move
the cursor with their minds when the
computer was connected to a mechanical
hand the stroke victim could open and
close the hand with their brain activity
similar stuff has been done with monkeys
controlling robotic arms with this kind
of technology we can potentially restore
movement to people who can't move and
communication to people who can't speak
we can even work out what people are
seeing and thinking by measuring their
brain activity much of this research
involves implants in the brain rather
than M eg but it's great when M AG can
be used because it's so easy and
non-invasive but yeah the point is that
technologies like M AG are taking us
closer and closer to Luke Skywalker
robot hands and mind-reading
in summary magneto encephalography works
by using super sensitive magnetism
detectives called squids to measure and
locate the electrical activity of the
brain you've got to do it in a shielded
room and with special cooling but it's
relatively easy to do and has great
spatial and temporal resolution thanks
for watching subscribe for more quick
clear explanations and analysis on stuff
like Game of Thrones Cheers
you